a ready at dawn studio exec has
responded to questions around the order
1886 game length saying that a normal
playthrough will be between 8 and 10
hours I'm set bored with your GS news
update on Sunday a video emerged on
YouTube showing the full game being
played seemingly as fast as possible and
finishing in about five hours this quick
playthrough suggested to the campaign
lengths hood theoretically be as short
as five hours however ready at Dawn's
Chief Technical Officer Andrea passinho
has challenged this assumption according
to paraphrases published by jewel
shockers facina claimed it at a normal
pace and difficulty level you can finish
the game in a window between eight and
ten hours he is also reported to have
said that playing in hard mode would
require at least 12 hours play these
figures he told journalists were
calculated by ready at Dawn's internal
teams speaking in an interview with
videogamer.com ready at dawn chief
executive officer reverse Surya also
explained that as games continue to
improve graphically the bar for visual
quality set by the order will become the
norm I'm just excited because things are
going to start looking better and better
and they're going to play better and
we're going to be able to do every
single type of game in this kind of
visual fidelity he said meanwhile he
also denied claims the order is a qte
game saying the QuickTime events in the
game are sparse the order 1886 launches
across Europe North America and
Australia on februari 20th exclusively
for ps4 so what type of game do you
think deserves this level of visual
fidelity do let me know in the comments
and keep your eye on gamespot com
tomorrow for a full review of the order
1886
you